encuentra una serie de potencias df
donde f es 6 entre 1 más x al cubo y
aquí nos están pidiendo cualquier serie
de potencias de efe y aquí como nos
están pidiendo cualquier serie podemos
escoger la serie de mclaren que suele
ser la más sencilla de todas porque está
centrada en cero y por eso podemos
llegar directamente a la función y
simplemente evaluarla en cero después de
evaluar la primera derivada en cero la
segunda derivada en cero y así seguirnos
y después utilizar la fórmula de la
serie de mclaren para desarrollar esta
expresión usando las derivadas evaluadas
en cero ahora aquí también nos vamos a
encontrar con problemas porque si es
bastante fácil evaluar a efe de cero y
también es bastante fácil evaluar f
prima de 0 0
cuando tratamos de evaluar la segunda
derivada de f en 0 o la tercera o la
cuarta se va volviendo un proceso cada
vez más complicado es cierto este
problema se puede simplificar un poco
podemos primero encontrar la serie de
mclaren para f
igual a 6 entre 1 + sur donde u es igual
a x al cubo entonces encontramos la
serie de mac loring para esta expresión
y luego sustituimos la uv por x al cubo
y hacer este truco realmente hace que
sea un problema más fácil y es una forma
fácil de resolverlo pero
la forma más fácil de encontrar una
serie de potencias para esta función es
decir algo así como hey espera un
segundo esta expresión esta forma que
tenemos aquí esta expresión racional se
ve idéntica a la suma de una serie
geométrica bueno detengámonos un segundo
para recordar cómo son las series
geométricas una serie de geométrica se
ve así el primer término es a el segundo
término es a por r donde a es el término
anterior y r es la razón común más ahora
voy a volver a multiplicar por r y nos
queda a por r al cuadrado más
a por ere a la tercera potencia y luego
así nos seguimos una y otra vez
multiplicando el término anterior por r
ahora nosotros sabemos que la suma de
una serie geométrica es igual a
el primer término entre 1 - la razón
común r
ok esto es simplemente la suma de una
serie geométrica y observa nuestra
definición de la función
efe es muy parecida a la suma de una
serie geométrica por ejemplo aquí
podríamos decir que este 6 es a
y luego y también podemos decir que
menos rs-x a la 3
pero hay una mejor forma de decir esto y
es decir que por acá tenemos uno menos
menos x al cubo y ahora podríamos decir
que r es igual a menos x al cubo y listo
ya con esto encontramos un desarrollo de
f en una serie de potencias por aquí la
a es igual a 6 y la r es igual a menos x
al cubo así es que podemos escribir a
efe como una serie geométrica y vamos a
hacerlo paso por paso aquí el primer
término es a o sea es un 6
más el segundo término es 6 otra vez por
nuestra razón común pero la razón común
es menos x a la 3 o sea que aquí estamos
multiplicando por menos x a la 3 pero
este término se puede reescribir de otra
forma lo podemos escribir como menos 6 x
x a la 3 y luego vamos a multiplicar
este término por la razón común menos x
a la 3 y eso nos va a quedar bueno pues
se multiplicó esto por - x a la 3 lo que
nos queda es más 6 x x a la 6
y aquí otra vez vamos a multiplicar por
menos x a la 3 y nos queda menos
x a la 9 y este proceso sigue y sigue
infinitamente aquí vamos a sumar el
término x menos x a la 3 o sea que nos
queda aún más
por equis a la 12 y podemos seguir y
seguir y seguir y seguir y seguir y
listo esta es la serie de mack loring de
efe y el truco aquí fue no tener que
hacer todo este proceso que queríamos
hacer por acá el truco fue darnos cuenta
de que esta expresión se parece a la
suma de una serie geométrica y se puede
considerar una serie geométrica y
entonces podemos usar esta serie
geométrica para encontrar una serie de
potencias que represente a efe y así
podemos usar esa serie geométrica como
el desarrollo en serie de potencias de
nuestra función f
ese es un truco muy útil